I would like to ask you about this as
well,
because as a,
as a man would go yuck pain in a country
like Sweden,
you have to,
I would say that I think a lot of boys
at least,
or I'm confused what it means to be a
man.
And then you have these public figures,
adult males admitting to collective
guilt and trying to be sort of the new
new mail,
uh,
which admits to gill feminist,
the good man.
And if you are
fat Tomcat of a man resting on top of
the warm TV,
who's,
what would you say moral virtue consists
in his harmlessness exactly.
What,
what's,
I mean how,
what's the advice to give to,
because what I find,
I see a lot of men trying to find their
way and
find out what it means to be a man.
And I think that's a lot of them turns
to you and a,
or a person like Jocko Willink and let,
let interviewed you.
And because you're,
you're,
uh,
and why do you think that it's,
I mean,
is it the because it doesn't seem so
you,
you're not sugarcoating life that you're
not giving them
no.
Well,
the funny thing about,
well there's a couple of things that I'm
doing that are different from what
people usually do.
You know,
so in the last 20 years,
the constant message to young people is
self esteem,
feel good about yourself.
It's like,
I don't buy that.
I think that you look at yourself in the
mirror and you think,
Jesus Christ,
I could be a hell of a lot better than I
am.
And so,
and the thing is there's nothing more
complimentary to tell a young person
than that.
So like,
look at you,
you're a wreck.
Grow the hell up.
There's so much more to you than your
manifesting.
Then you can hardly imagine it.
It's like,
well,
you think that's a criticism?
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's a great compliment.
It's like,
look at how much more you could bring
out into the world.
Get your aggression under control,
strengthen yourself.
Like take on some responsibilities.
See if you have enough bloody courage to
tell the truth.
Put your life together.
Stop whining.
Hmm.
The man eat that up because no one's
ever told them that.
Which just makes breaks my heart.
Yeah,
it's so bad.
And you know,
the boys are pulling out of everything.
They're pulling out a university,
they're pulling out of life,
they're pulling out of marriage,
and,
and because of that,
they're more awkward and unsophisticated
than they would otherwise be in much
more prone to make sexual errors,
some of which are,
you know,
predatory malevolence in a small
proportion of cases.
But it's another one of those
situations,
you know,
like imagine that one in a hundred men
are sexual predators.
Yeah,
probably.
Maybe it's one in 50 but let's go with
one in a hundred.
Well,
they,
that small proportion commit all of this
sexual predation.
Like if you look at criminals,
it's a parade.
Oh,
distribution.
Again,
5% of the criminals produce something
like,
well,
the overwhelming majority of the crimes,
right?
It's a small coterie of specialized
people who are responsible for all the
criminality.
Lots of people are in prison because
they did one highness thing,
you know,
like they got enraged or drunk and did
something violent.
But there's the serial criminal types
and they're the ones that are,
they do all,
they,
they like we had one guy in Toronto for
example,
who ran a bike theft ring and they
finally nailed him.
And like there weren't any bikes stolen
in Toronto after that.
It was just him and his little coterie
of,
you know,
organized bike thieves and these guys
that are being outed,
the serial predators,
they are responsible like one,
one spread predatory guy can prey on who
knows,
500 females,
thousand females in the lifetime,
you know.
So
it's almost seems like,
I mean this is
a lot of guys,
I was one of these guys who sort of turn
away from society for,
for awhile,
like into computer games,
like the slacker identity where,
which is sort of,
I guess it's always been there like you
turned to a like away from all
responsibilities,
but the opportunities to do this,
it's so much Florida now,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's the lost boys,
like in Peter Pan Right there,
it never land and they never grow up.
And Peter Pan is their leader.
That's,
that's the story.
And it's not surprising because it's
easier to do.
It's easier to occupy yourself trivially
than it is to do something difficult.
So like there's a big tendency in that
direction to begin with because it's
easier to do nothing than to take
responsibility.
It's easier to play games than to plan
for the future.
It's easier to be resentful and angry
than it is to be,
you know,
to shoulder you're vulnerability
properly.
And then when you add on to that,
the idea that if you go out into the
world and try to strive forward,
that you're nothing but a predatory
patriarch,
then well,
it's just one more.
It's just the icing on the cake.
You know,
I had a friend who was like that he
pulled back from the world,
um,
and bill because he believed that active
masculinity was a pathological force.
And um,
he poisoned himself terribly because of
that.
And he committed suicide when he was 40.
He hooked an exhaust,
you know,
up hose onto his exhaust pipe and gassed
himself up in the mountains in Alberta.
And that was the logical consequence of,
of his self hatred.
It's like,
well,
if you're so pathological,
why don't you just do it yourself in and
hiding like that is,
you know,
it's not,
that's obviously not the full fledged
manifestation of that,
but,
but it's,
it's,
believe me,
it's on the road.
So,
and so,
yeah,
I've been talking to all these young
guys,
they come to my biblical lectures for
example,
and the message is always the same.
It's like stand the hell up.
Get the hell out there in the world.
Take local responsibility,
put yourself together because there's
nothing more dangerous than a weak man.
And the problem is,
is that we're encouraging men to be weak
because we have this pathological idea
that there's that strength and tyranny
or the same thing.
And that's that Animus I was talking
about earlier though women,
it's not only women,
but the feminist types,
let's say,
who insist upon the pathology of the
Patriarchy cannot distinguish between
competence and power.
They see everything because they have
this vague and undifferentiated sense of
masculinity.
They say they see everything that is
associated with authority as equivalent
to tyranny.